you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Leech s
org and I just got paired up playing a
5-2 game ok let's go for a Kings Indian
defense see what white throws at us
uh-huh all righty
Oh interesting
well I feel like I should be striking it
d4 how do I do that let's play e5 right
now see if I can make that pawn flinch
I've already missed played this we're
gonna say Knight there yeah I guess so
huh okay we're gonna try a piece sac
we're gonna run with it yeah how do you
like that just a few moves in and guess
who's down the exchange okay we're gonna
try to focus on deform a little bit I
could play Knight check and then jump
into here
let's first play here I might want to
take this pawn my Knights defended okay
so let's jump in here I guess King there
is coming up I only have one move I can
move my bishop and be attacking their
bishop my bishop is actually playing the
game for as long as my knight is on d4
this is the weakest square in their camp
okay
Knight takes Knight might be natural but
it drops material Bishop g5 maybe f6
yeah I could even consider getting this
knight into play striking at this pawn I
have a passed pawn let's not be too
quick take care
I could take here and then go after him
but they get the bishop at the end I
take c4 King here I guess you know let's
take here on this pawn I'm guessing f3
interesting let's maybe keep my knight
secure clamp down on this structure here
maybe rook up and over as an idea hmm
this feels right let's do this first my
knight could be challenged with Bishop
to e7 although maybe I could come into
here okay hmm I could jump into this
square
um let's go rook up maybe rip to c6 is
an idea with an Knight to b3 yeah okay
so now I guess they're looking to
dislodge my bishop really not too afraid
of that let's go here might be three and
then crash through on this square or was
their idea to play here and then scoop
up this pawn actually I'm threatening to
take on this square and then take here
instead of this Knight B 3 idea I can
maybe be more direct
okay so I could go in for this now I
think I'm the better side all of a
sudden they takes bishop and then Bishop
here mm-hmm
because I could have a passed pawn
pushed and connect you with my light
square bishop all right
it's kind of cash out some I have this
defended play d3 b5 my bishop is a
really strong piece and I should
probably be going for that right now
actually I have to be a little bit
careful you know they might run into a
little trick on d3 rook f1 I have a
bishop check okay I think I want to go
with d5 first let's go with b5 rook c1
bishop here
is to play d3 and then move my rook off
of the C file okay so now there's a
disconnect let's get this in here so
this is really strong configuration I
think they're going to invest the
material rook d1 and then sacrifice here
meanwhile I should be shooting for this
move yeah I have to break this open my
King needs to play it's another way to
view it this is an endgame so I need to
move my F pawn to get my King rollin
he's out of play let's occupy this open
file before they do now they're gonna
struggle to get this guy back right
given time I want my King right here
let's get active first kind of
immobilize these guys g4 comes with a
cost I don't want to trade rooks then I
lose control they could easily rely upon
the dark squares mm-hmm prove the King
probably want to stay off of this file
King here interesting
well if I play King here King d2 and
then there's gonna be ripped there hmm
how do I get my King across okay let's
start with this in there I have to drop
my rook back I guess here here there's a
pawn break yeah I need to avoid that
exchange thinking this hmm they're gonna
play rook to e5 and put pressure on c5
so I think I have to do this
b7 rookie five and then I don't know
what I'm doing with this pawn so it
feels like I need to expand some with
these guys strong move hmm I play here
with this I mind I'll try it takes pawn
ahead Bishop check I guess they could
drop the bishop or the rook back to f1
hmm okay maybe I come over here I was
considering this but kind of locks in my
bishop so I'm looking to take advantage
of these squares they might be able to
play a five here and not takes g4 I take
with my Bishop g4 or even with the pawn
no okay Bishop f5 you know let's go with
that
and now push with before I guess like to
get into this square might be able to
get a past a pawn or maybe connected
passers let's take with the pawn 35
seconds it shouldn't even be as close as
it is with me dropping the exchange like
that maybe just scoot the King off huh
no let's keep the rook out I don't even
want to deal with rook h8 I have this
square covered
now after takes takes rook c2 is pretty
serious with the King on f2 a check the
King could move and defend the rook can
they dislodge my bishop from defending
here they could still go for this
sacrifice just to get rid of this guy
but I am making some headway here on the
Queen side with these three versus these
two okay so I guess they're preparing g4
is hitting really fast King here maybe
that was too fast to do that okay let's
get behind this guy g4i push hmm I think
I have to look to cut the rook off
Bishop to e2 King takes pawn I push hmm
yikes
I played Bishop here there was rook
takes rook takes rook check alright so
this was my idea
my king up I'm going after to this rook
I want to put pressure on that rook I
couldn't go there because of rook check
King here
look to dislodge the king I keep
pressure on the rook they might have to
play here
rook b7 to b6 is my idea
mm-hmm the rook is may be out of play
actually takes Bishop rook takes rook
there is no king take C far because I
take the rook am I not just pushing
through though
yeah I'm pushing through lucky lucky
lucky
all right let's avoid any skewers and
queen here
just some fork has got to be in the air
they're under 30 hmm let's start with
the check and probably just push
threatening and mating - you know lucky
lucky lucky
yikes
man okay so that a five move no good I
mean I know there's some compensation
because of the dark square we excuse me
there's some compensation because the
dark square weaknesses but yeah there
should have been a clean way for white I
think at least no no let's see well I
feel like I just want to put on the
engine with this one is this even okay
or what
let's see 'if I've yes or no no it's not
losing is this an idea
is an idea there is some compensation
tonight f3 okay so it's not losing but
yeah kinda tricky huh that's so easy to
convert only a half on advantage it's a
full exchange that block is down here
but I can make use of that d4 square
interesting okay what did one do right
around here instead of Knight c5 no it
does like night c5 there is this capture
huh and then takes here oh you know what
I wasn't seeing it that the knight is
there to recapture you know this is a
really strong post for the night and
then dropping in here soon g3 here can
be offset with this structure to
neutralize the light squared bishop now
I didn't see that for some reason I was
seeing it as after takes here I have to
do this so I guess this is an idea to
take on e4 and I just recaptured past
pawn now he force hit f3 hmm it's still
tough on advantage nothing more you look
up an over idea which it seems to be
fine with doesn't like that wants to
take first and then King takes rook here
oh that's sharp by playing rook c3 right
away what's the issue with that they
could cut off my bishop and now on takes
there's King takes and if I take with
the bishop King takes here mm-hmm
and if I take like
now they're going to be successful with
exchanging rooks it's very important
that I keep the rooks on the board
otherwise why can easily operate on the
dark squares and I can't gain control
over them
I need to at least have a piece around
in other words like when we did get to
it's roughly equal again right around
here so let's say this moment the
exchange of rooks which it wants to go
for right now I can't I don't see how I
gained control over the dark squares I
always have to keep them in question
keep a piece around that could maybe
control d2 one day or c3 when I had
these guys pushing let's go back just a
little bit more I went maybe a little
bit too fast there hang up yeah so that
wasn't a good idea yeah what what
happened in the game I played here and
then went back after the King came over
so I should just immediately improve my
King position instead of this I think
the reasoning I gave gave at the time
was to stop these guys from advancing
but I should get on with inviting a new
piece into the game King up seven okay I
keep the rook on rookie five yeah now
they're know they're better here with
just blasting open the position yeah
this is this is the right idea because
right now there's only one open file
white should be shooting for more pawn
breaks on this wing and the on the Kings
side and then it's really tough to worry
about entering here and maybe here if my
King comes over never could maybe get
behind if five is better yeah this
already gave me a little
as soon as I saw these light square
weaknesses but even even so I think they
have f5 here takes their g4 and unn
takes there's still g4 yes you know this
is the right idea for white create pawn
exchanges let these rooks let their
presence really be felt the way to do
that is to create as many open files as
possible I only have one work they have
to you know and then they kind of went
astray huh oh that's an interesting move
c5 right away and untaxed a3 Wow that's
getting really sharp hmm takes here
comes c6 that's decisive once he's here
there's no stopping these guys that's a
pretty cool move sequence right here
so in rook g4 I did not even consider
this push takes and then here that's
real nice guess it's still hold a bull
with rook c5 takes takes takes the rook
has to go there Wow three passed pawns
have a passed pawn
yikes what an ending that would have
been but just the idea at least is
interesting I didn't even consider c5
right here at c5 now they blockade and
now they're winning I wanted to play
Bishop here but they could take
there's no time to Queen because that's
Czech and the king could return to stop
this guy so they're back to winning
right around here at +2
but they allowed my King to get active
yeah their King was cut off they have to
move the rook and now it's tricky they
have to take my bishop here yeah so as
soon as I have pressure on this rook
they should play rook here and now I'm
still in this pin and suppose I go here
get push that way you're stopping rook
takes pawn with check and how do I ever
get out of this pin so this this was my
only hope to try and enter here but if
they just stop that one idea once I have
pressure here I'm restricting the king
the king is now freed up and the rook is
stopping rip b7 and I really wouldn't
have anything as mentioned I'm in a pin
and I don't see how to get out of it
they have a strong blockade over the
dark squares hmm they pushed instead and
now White's losing they have to go with
this and then push but even here it's
tricky isn't it yeah yeah it's still
pretty tricky here it's a big race yeah
rook to be 2 would have pretty much been
decisive here instead of f5 interesting
game interesting idea
this e5 move I don't know if I would
play it again interesting activity give
up the exchange like this mm-hmm
I don't know what are your thoughts on
this one I'll throw it to you or what
are your thoughts on giving up the
exchange like this and focusing on the
weak point D for these minor pieces
maybe taking on a 2 and jumping the
night in to d4
kind of interesting I don't know feel
free to share your thoughts on this one
would you be a fan of maybe sacking the
exchange like that as black let me know
in the comment section below and as
usual I hope you got something on this
video or at the very least found it a
little bit entertaining that quick
imbalance right out of the gate anyhow
that's all for now take care bye
you